hello everyone welcome back to a cup of
bunker saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of San Peter Berg and the
hotel kappa blanka faces his old
opponent from the 1911 sunset bus the
internment it's Davidian offski a former
World Chess Championship challenger who
in 1910 challenged Emanuele a score for
the title but well Emanuel Lasker pretty
much wiped the floor with yanovskiy
maybe not gameplay wise but the
definitely result wise is the the score
was 8 to 0 in favor of Lasker with three
drawers so quite uh you know just a a
massacre so to say but you know a strong
opponent and nonetheless he he had a
poor match against against Lasker that's
I mean it's that's the way it is but
already in this tournament Ian offski
has the video is the only player who
defeated dr. ziggurat Arash and some of
you said that you wouldn't mind seeing
the standings after each round well I
don't really have the option of seeing
the standings after each round maybe if
I had a terse tournament book I don't
but I have prepared here's my mighty
notepad I have prepared some of the
opponent some of the players who are
doing better in this tournament so
Capablanca is in the lead the only
player without a loss so far with five
points three wins and four draws and
then we have a lien with four and a half
points with three wins three draws and
one loss dancing Bert Irish who lost the
game to Yanam ski but also has three
wins three draws and one loss Lasker has
two wins 4 draws and one loss that makes
four and a half points and Frank James
Marshall has two in four rows and 1 loss
same as Emanuel a square with four
points so a couple blank are doing
excellently and we'll see how it goes
here in the 1911 tournaments of San
Sebastiano Blanca defeated the on/off
scheme now which of the black pieces but
now Capablanca is the one with the white
pieces so we have e 4 we have E 5 and
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now Bishop
to b5 do Rua Lopez a 6 we have more fees
defense Bishop characters and c6 the
exchange variation
I will decap choice on c6 and now Knight
to c3 and here we have Bishop to c5
it's interesting two rounds before the
game capelin Karnofsky last pair played
f6 against relax and relation and i Hin
got an excellent position out of this
game but India and Lasker was able to be
Talia him and that's just how Lasker mo
often times played he didn't mind any
any position no matter how uncomfortable
it was but he just wanted to make make
it as uncomfortable for his opponents
you know as much as he could and often
it worked but here we don't have f6 here
after a couple months Knight to c3
Bishop to c5 bian offski of course the
d5 pawn is off limits if if Knight
captures then Bishop captures on f2 King
characters in 24 picks up the night
perhaps it is playable I mean if you
still Castle Rock f1 and then
artificially Castle but not not
something you want to do but okay after
Bishop c5 d 3 by capablanca I with
Bishop to g4 and now Bishop to e3
offering a trade of dark square Bishop
so we have Bishop captures pawn captures
messing up couple uncas pawn structure
in the middle but if anything it's just
you know strengthens the center at some
point the d4 will be played and kappa
blanka does have a semi-open F file for
his rook I we have Queen to e7 and now
comes castles jános go so castles but he
castles Queen side and here we have a
very strong move by Capablanca the
bishop pinning the knight attacking the
Queen well x-raying the Queen here rook
also doing the same thing along the D
file so Queen to e1 getting out of this
pin getting out of this uncomfortable
D file also giving more protection to
the e3 pawn and also if this Knight
moves
the Queen is supporting the pawns
advancement to b4 as the Queen here is
you know that doesn't really want that
we have nice to h6 by an auskey and here
comes a move that many people say pretty
much just shows how brilliant Capablanca
is and the width with what ease he plays
in the games here couple Monica plays
rook to be one because capablanca wants
to push a4 b4 and b5 if he can do this
then positionally he's just winning so
here he wants to prepare it
Queen is currently guarding before you
don't really have a good move with your
knight
so your Queen would be guarding before
so just work to be one now a4 b4 b5 is
coming
black can't really do all that much
about to this first the black goes f6
strengthens the e5 pawn and a cup of
Blanca proceeds with his plan we have b4
and now comes Knight to f7 the knight
now comes into the game as with this f6
we have made this possible a for
preparing b5 and just like that Bishop
captures rook captures and now comes b6
preparing that after other couple Blanca
advances the pawn to close the position
with a 5 and capablanca still goes on
with his plan with b5 C capture some
b-58 captures and now a5 of course Janos
is not interested in opening up to the
position as his King is there on c8 and
the now comes Knight to d5 Queen has to
move as the Queen is under attack Queen
c5 and now see for and what couple lanka
did here he saw that you know skis night
who was awkwardly placed on h6 okay now
it's on f7 but from f7 it will take a
whole lot of moves to challenge White's
knight on d5 also that night being
supported by the C pour a C pawn and by
the e pawn is pretty much a monster
night and the d3 pawn that's a weakness
is not really a weakness because there's
no way you can ever move this night from
here so black now has no useful plan
like an out just wait and see what
capablanca does we have nice to g5 REE
maneuvering with an attack on the rook
rook F 2 and now nice to east 6 and it's
still not possible to challenge this
night even with this night it's very
unlikely you will be able to push this
pawn and of course you cannot you can
ever go to f4 as d3 pawn pretty much
covers that so III not not at all a
weakness but ok Queen to c3 now by
Capablanca and here you might think okay
black still has nothing to do so what
what's the play with black black just
plays rook to d7 makes room for the
other group to enter the game and now
you can see that there's really no way
that well you'll ever push this as then
just pawn captures and then both
and night are attacking the b6 spawn
you're never pretty much pushing this DF
v square is covered by the by the rook
if you try and move with the pawns on
the King side the night covers at the f6
pawn also the rook will be attacking
that so black has no active plan here
black can just sit and wait and well the
only one that has an active plan here is
capablanca so what does cup of monka
play rook to d1 now it's finally time to
make this d3 weakness pawn as strengths
and d4 is coming there's not all that
much black can do here just giving an
example if jános key plays a some
irrelevant move on the King side d4 is
pretty much a game-winning move he
captures you will play pawn captures the
Queen is under attack you have to move
now comes c5 just you know continuing
with the attack we have a pawn captures
and now Queen captures on a5 there's a
threat of Queen to a8 checkmate so you
would have to prevent this somehow let's
say we go King b7 but now comes rope to
a-1 again you're threatening to jump all
the way into the position also you're
preventing rook to be developed to a8
and now after rook to b8 making the room
for the king and c8 white could just
finish the game very easily I'm sure you
all see it it is e5 attacking the Queen
and the Queen has nowhere to go
the pawn is covering c6 and a sex the
night is covering b6 and it's game over
once the Queen moves for example you or
even capture once and then the Queen
eater has to move or capture the night
then it's going to a6 checkmate so a lot
of poison to the position d4 is coming
and yanovskiy tries king - b7 aa couple
monk at one point said that maybe King
today it would have been better but I
don't think of a Blanca was giving that
that much thought so the attack is
pretty much the same if the King goes to
d8 so a couple uncle proceeded with the
continue with the attack d4
we have Queen to b6 and now rook to c2
just increase increasing the pressure
along the C file c5 is coming we have
ecad force on d4e captures on d4 and now
again for the lack of a better move
Yonex we played Knight to f4 but it just
doesn't work so I would ask you
pause the video but you all know which
move is coming of course it's c5 no
pretty much pointless to pause the video
you know after the Queen moves c6 will
win the rook as the king will be checked
so there's not much to do here tonight
captures pawn captures the queen is
still under attack Queen captures and if
I was played in here capablanca just
played c6 check and he ran off tsuki
loses a rook now this is move 26 but
even on the previous move yanovskiy
could have easily resigned perhaps he
didn't want to he didn't want maybe he
didn't want the game to be classified as
a miniature or who knows what maybe he
just wanted to prolong the game but
either way he continues playing here he
played king b8 couple Monica played C
capture Sun d7 we have Queen character
Sun d7 and I'll cover longer just push
the pawn now he's up a whole rook it's
pretty much the same whatever he plays
everything is winning rook e8
and now even d6 yeah we have C capture
Sun d6 and now after Queen to c6 it was
in this position that Davi deunov ski
resided the game as either Queen
captures or rock actress is coming but
basically a black has just done a whole
roof so there's no point whatsoever in
continuing here and it's a Garrick as
part of a said that that's a dry tedious
play second deunov ski and that he he
couldn't play like that against
Capablanca so he often went for this
these attacking lines which didn't work
against Kappa Blanc and then it's well
this is the end result but yeah it's an
interesting game that we can all learn a
lot from and there's a very famous game
between and DK and making in the Viktor
Korchnoi from the 1974 quarterfinal
candidates
we're making employed the same idea Ruby
won a 4 B 4 B 5 and defeated Viktor
Korchnoi although cautionary
won the match in the end but still was a
very nice game I will put a link to it
in the description below if you just
want to check out that game as well Sam
now what do you think about the game I
mean pretty much everything up to this
point was you know brilliant playback
Capablanca and this rook to be one move
just shows how easy chest comes to
Capablanca and
you know black also has attacking
potential black and just go g6 f5 I mean
there are there are ideas here you could
make a nice real if you go here go here
make some and capture capture here make
it an IG four moves there are ideas here
but white is just too fast with him with
this a4 b4 b5 idea but yeah now you
could perhaps use this in your own games
okay it today in modern chess very
unlikely that you will see this kind of
aggressive chest you know with opposite
side castles but if you do you know make
sure make sure you employ such such an
attack if possible so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and you know if
your opponent plays a brilliant game
always make sure you congratulate him
and don't just drag the game on okay if
there is company if there are
complications possible if there's poison
to the position where you are hoping
your opponent will make a mistake then
you can continue the game but if you're
just down a whole rook you know just
don't drag the game out you know shaker
upon his hand and congratulate him from
the heart as he created this beautiful
game and it will make both of you feel
great
I say once again I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you're enjoying the
capablanca so saga so far Capablanca now
still in the lead that we're gonna I'm
gonna try and check up on the results
before we go into the next game and we
are getting nearer and nearer to the to
the end of the first part of the
tournament and as you all know five of
the players who have the best results in
the first part of part of the tournament
are then going into the second part of
the tournament where five of them are
going into a double round-robin and you
know as I've already mentioned all hell
will break loose so you know stay tuned
I would like to thank Walid al body
Louis bomb it Anton baklanov Wisla
Santos and the Josef compression in for
a contribution to my channel thank you
what I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serie
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully what's more
interesting content and well checking up
on on it's pretty much the end of the
match between Leela and stockfish
gonna check up on that as well thank you
all and I will see you soon